six months ago when we first realized it
like if I touched what I'm touching
right now the way I'm touching right now
it was massive pain no I like this stuff
I'm super into it let me show you let me
show you like this what do you what do
you think of that matter is that hurt
what are you good yeah that hurts right
and I'm not really this right so sorry
let me see her oh it's fine it's fine no
no come on stop I don't give a [ __ ]
[Music]
what's up vlog here in London just got
in from LA we're headed to a client
meeting strap it up been fighting a cold
all week so that's been interesting
energy wise but a lot of good stuff
should be fired up for 18 super focus
like if you've noticed like less post on
Instagram the last like week or two like
just really in CEO mode so feel really
good about that got a lot done in the
last couple of weeks of the year and the
head of now to see a senior client got
client meetings here not in London until
tonight at the holiday party bamm and
you should interview some peace for the
holiday party
that'll be a good episode
[Music]
put a vlog taking control battens been
doing to reach our minds
most of this episodes can be the holiday
party I'm sure he's going to transition
to it now but we've been doing a
shitload of meetings going super well
[Music]
so this is unbelievable to me I've had a
bad back my whole life cuz I heard it at
18 at my dad's liquor store Adam that's
right out of everything I've ever done
in my life in the last three weeks six
weeks there's this you know stick that
Eric saw me using with my trainer in
Sweden in Sweden
Rory Stockholm rolling
soft itchy work like like tissue quality
has changed my life and when I think
about all the massages all the
stretching all the working out that
Jordan taking what is a stick in essence
and like rolling my adductor rolling
rolling yeah I I literally tell Jordan
every two days I'm like the world needs
to know about like I feel like there's
no conversation neck neck has like been
huge because I travel so much and sleep
I don't you sort of feel this like when
you know when you sleep in awkward ready
for ready for this six months ago when
we first realized it like if I touched
what I'm touching right now the way I'm
touching right now it was massive pain
no I like this stuff I'm super into it
let me show you let me show you like
this what do you what do you think that
Babbitt is that hurt are you good yeah
that hurts right and I'm not really this
right sarens let me see her
oh it's the guide it's fine no no come
on stop I'm sorry I don't give a [ __ ]
let me just see it real quick let me
know actually what about this one I say
does that hurt or no no yeah yours is
actually you have you don't have neck
problems do you let me see I want to say
I want the Hoyt
with me no let me see your leg one more
time we need a print of lot I mean it
this was really good that's Eric
what about Eric let me see yours come on
because yours is really bad right - oh
jeez are so tight like this is
incredible like I'm I can't be able to I
used to be here when I started no no
Betty knees you can go further no you're
not trying to do for a fact go you know
you know that's hamstrings right yeah
what are you babbling like you look come
on no no you bet your knees a little bit
too much start again no I stop at your
knees brows kick your kick your ass back
out okay
pretty good man why sure so goodness no
that was pretty good do you see Eric he
says that
just say sorry you get all the time much
respect rather they are hopefully can
get energy no seriously in yeah and
thank you so much blessings Bravo you
thank you spending a lot of time with
people thank you brother have a good
holidays
Thank You Man so here on the boat which
has become a London office tradition and
it's going super well having a meeting
with Raisa on my team I don't think you
caught that for you capturing that be
wrong bad job Ivan the BJP is my
favorite the bad job babban anyway
planning a lot of Asia stuff with Raisa
now we're about to give the awards which
the London office does so I'm excited
for that and just uh just a productive
day nothing done
it is best expat to integrate into
British culture so let's see who that is
okay and the winner is Claire
[Applause]
so
the correct pronunciation is gift brat
[Applause]
the hard work the efforts the passion
that everybody put into 2017 you guys
saw an email from me a couple of weeks
ago kind of just alluding to how excited
about 2018 I I was we've had an enormous
amount of pretty substantial wins now
we'll start announcing over the next
couple weeks which is great but it's
funny I got to say a very similar thing
to Chattanooga from a different angle
when I look across some what we're doing
and I think about 2017 as I think
everybody does this time of year you
start to miss a little bit something
very exciting happened in London this
year for me what's really exciting to me
and and I think a lot about what Eric
and Ryan and Jenna put into it and the
rest of you I think the thing that
excites me the most is the brief law you
know in in this is gonna be very narrow
so I know not everybody's into Star Wars
but it just came out the you know much
like the Death Star where there's this
one random completely ridiculous flaw in
the system of the ultimate machine I
really I really do think of vaynermedia
ironically in a Death Star way which is
I really do think we're gonna win I
really I really really I do plan to
destroy the world so congrats you're
part of it I'm just so grateful and so
thankful because what we've been able to
do and let me rephrase what you've been
able to do in this office on the thing
that I'm most fearful of which is how do
you guys play with each other when
you're on different sides of the ball is
has given me enormous confidence
and has made me greedy on our
capabilities over the next decade and
definitely going into new the new year I
will tell you that the last hundred or
so days 150 days of this office
resetting and getting there Northstar in
working collaboratively in this world is
a bigger feet and a more impactful feet
than you realize because it allows the
CEO who's disproportionately navigating
a lot of excitement on what we're
capable of and so I thank you guys very
very much from the department heads to
the person that started the most
recently that's on this boat it's a very
very very big deal it is truly our
kryptonite it is truly our only
vulnerability because everything else
I truly believe is on its way we are on
the right side of history we do things
that we believe in for me holiday
parties are easy it's fun everybody's
unwinding but I pay attention I've been
to about 30 of them at this point like
I'm very very very happy with the tone
of this office with the ambition and and
I hope you enjoy the rest of the night
thanks
[Applause]
hey-ya
okay really
that is the most ludicrous [ __ ] I've
ever heard in my life I like the Vikings
are you like expand I'm rooting for them
heavily I'm Casey Keith I love a casual
14 hours in London just got a bunch of
bad news from some business losses some
[ __ ] pissed for about another 13
seconds that's where I'm at 11:38
walking in the cold in London [ __ ]
angry
[Music]
[Music]